so Matt Walsh's talking points right
um so one of the things that he says is
you know will the stats save 50 but you
know you're an individual you know you
can beat those odds because you're an
individual so he's so he's trying to
separate you from the stats saying that
you don't have to participate in those
stats you don't have to be a participant
in those failures if you choose not to
be
that's a fair statement
only the problem with that though is
that you're only responsible for
yourself and what you can control
you're not able to control her you're
not able to control her decisions you're
not able to control the decisions that
she makes as a consequence of her past
for example a woman that's shared her
body with a number of guys is a far
worse long-term relationship uh use her
partner wife
um
versus one that's a virgin one that's a
virgin the chances of her being unhappy
experience and displeasure wanting to
leave the marriage is very very small I
think it's less than uh like 30 percent
whereas if she shared her body with
something like three or four guys plus
the number goes up to like over sixty
percent seventy percent right and it
just keeps getting worse and the truth
of the matter is I think that most guys
acknowledge today that women have been
promiscuous with impunity uh you know
toxic feminists have been telling women
for decades now not for years but for
decades several decades back to back you
go girl uh if a man can do it you can do
it too go out there have fun right
and that in reality just makes it I mean
like where are these virgin women that
these guys are supposed to find that
also subscribe to religious values
wholeheartedly
um that would make vows so he said a few
things like State and principle no
divorce from the offset so you and your
future wife are to sit down and to State
and principle no matter how bad things
get we're not going to get divorced
isn't that the vows that you take when
you go before the church in your family
and you say in sickness and health and
richer and poorer and all that sort of
stuff we're not going to end this
um the church legitimately says when you
go before the um the priest or whoever
it is that you know performs a ceremony
and I know this because I had a
ceremonial wedding when I did mine there
is no divorce they they overtly
explicitly state it
very loudly and clearly you're never to
get divorced right
well how did that work out right it just
doesn't go that way they can say what
they want you know for the betterment of
their uh you know their Institution
but stating in principle there's going
to be no divorce from the office you
know from the onset you're going to
resolve all the well what if you sit
down and try to resolve all the issues
with your uh wife you know what if she's
just not cooperating what if she's
[__] and demanding and uh controlling
and um
you know just a difficult individual in
general you know how are you gonna hash
out these differences you're just not
um shared face you know was another one
he said well you know if you both
subscribe to what the faith says
you'll never untie the knot and that's
simply not true I've I've been doing
private phone consults with guys for
years now thousands upon thousands of
conversations I've had and I can't tell
you how many conversations I've had with
religious men and women when they got
together they subscribed to a faith a
shared faith that they both uh agreed on
wholeheartedly Hook Line and speaker
but what they don't tell you is that
women always reserve the right to change
their mind at any given time later on
down the road
it just happens
men change women change it happens
it just is it's a reality of the world
so whatever you agree on today may not
be something that you necessarily agree
on in seven years time in 12 years time
whatever it happens to be you may not
necessarily agree on those things in the
future and if you get bored as a woman
and we know that women get bored faster
in long-term relationships than men do
for men you know their interest in the
woman sort of declines slowly over time
whereas with women it just drops off
like a hockey stick
um this is not my these are not my words
this is Esther perel she's written a ton
of books on this she's covered it in TED
Talks she's covered it in her podcast
I've met her in person we've had
conversation like this is how it works
this is how it generally goes for most
relationships that's just how it is so
saying that you share a faith today is
going to be the end-all be-all is absurd
it's you know it's a nice thing to State
it's um it's Noble sure is it virtuous
of course
um but people change their mind and
women change their minds and you can't
control how a woman thinks
um the only parts of the world that you
can you know control is yourself are the
things you can do yeah you know we'll
talk about things that you can do that
would contribute to a long-standing
marriage perhaps you know if we put it
that way shared values was the other one
they said if you have shared values
that's going to minimize the risk
okay
you know
I'll
I'll vividly recount this call that I
had with a guy and this isn't the only
call that I had I've had a number of
these calls you know with guys
got married to her in the church she was
whatever Mormon from a family of 18
everybody's you know subscribed to this
religion sort of thing big big family
big church thing big Community sort of
thing
and she has the 2.1 kids we buy the
house seven years later you know the
kids are all in school she decides to go
to work
gets into HR gets into HR and some woke
company gets into HR and some woke
company that starts talking about things
like inclusivity and different kind of
rainbows and flags and pronouns and
voting habits and oh now we're starting
to talk about things like oppression
like it doesn't matter what you believe
today if you surround yourself or you
put yourself in an environment where
things go woke and weird and pollute the
belief system that you subscribe to you
know the faith things will change
um this is not new there's a bit that
Eddie Murphy did I think it was
um either raw or Delirious I can't
remember I'm actually talking about the
bit in my second book as I'm writing it
um but I have to go down and actually
get the actual name but I'm pretty sure
it's raw but he talks about picking up
he's like women here suck this is in the
80s
80s 90s 2000s we're in 2023 right now
we're talking almost four freaking
decades we're talking almost 40 years
ago he's talking about how women sucked
and his ideal situation would be to go
to Africa and get a naked woman on a
zebra
and bring her back to the West
only in a matter of years because she
starts hanging out with other Western
women you can't do this to you he can't
tell you what to do and run you and keep
you at home and all sort of stuff and
she's like I want half Eddie and like
the whole Auditorium erupts in laughter
and the reason why stand-up comedy is
funny is because there's truth in it and
that's why people laugh and that's why I
keep making reference to stand-up comedy
I should legit do an entire series on
stand-up comic bits where they break
down realities of the world okay the
cold hard truth
anyway shared values oh my favorite one
is abolish no fault divorce now if you
Google what no fault divorce is I have
it up here on my other screen
the Wikipedia definition is no fault
divorce is the dissolution of a marriage
that does not require showing of
wrongdoing by either party so in the
past fault needed to be uh presented to
the family court system to untie the
knot I.E uh she cheated on me she's
banging Kevin from sales I want out then
you know the courts would look at that
petition entertain it and then you know
if reasonable to untie the knot now
that might seem like a good idea abolish
no fault divorce this is what the tribe
cons this is what the daily wire guys
are all saying this is what Jeremy
boring you know was talking about
particularly Insidious and evil and all
these sorts of things let's say you
abolish and all no fault divorce and we
hop into time machine and we go back to
a time before there was no fault divorce
and you had to prove fault you had to
prove fault of the other party to untie
the knot
well golly gee if I remember correctly
as a kid there was a lot of people that
stayed married because they couldn't
untie the knot they would just bang
other people they would pretend they're
married they were pretend that they're
in love they would show up at family
events and functions and act like
everything's okay when you could tell
they hated each other and they would
disparage each other so they would just
stay together in misery now
that's how some of them acted the notion
that no fault or removing no fault
solves that is incredibly I mean you
want to talk about incredibly Insidious
and evil well we live in an environment
today where it's the hashtag metoo era
and how many great men have been
destroyed just from allegations of women
saying you did something to me 10 years
ago and then we've got Russell Brand
today you know I did a show about it the
other week
um they've basically either de-platform
him or they've left him on the platform
and demonetized that he can't earn
Revenue he's lost sponsors I think he
has you know dumped him all based on the
accusation without evidence or proof
because we're to believe all women so
gee let me think
women aren't happy is it entirely
possible because we have to believe all
women today that they might make up
reason for fault
he's financially abusive he doesn't give
me money to buy groceries he controls
you know the credit cards he you know
whatever happens to work today if they
remove no fault I guarantee you removing
no fault will have almost no impact on
the divorce rate it just won't because
this is the world that we live in today
where it's believe all women you know
without any evidence uh you know I said
the other day you know when I was doing
the other podcast I'm I'm surprised at
this point that some descendant of Eve
was a claim to it would say that there's
a me too on Adam you know because
there's no limitation period it's not
like you know if a credit card company
needs to sue you for not paying your
credit card bill it has to happen within
two years uh otherwise the limitation
period has passed and the courts aren't
going to entertain it right there's no
limitation period on things like me too
or women changing their mind on
something or women alleging something
without evidence it's just point the
finger blame and and then they get the
remedy that they want and that's the
world that we live in today so I think
the notion of abolishing no fault
divorce is going to fix things that's
just dumb and if anybody believes that
you're just dumb it ain't gonna fix
anything it ain't gonna solve anything
let's keep going
what else did he say the family court
system needs to be torn down and rebuilt
and by the way I've had a conversation
with Andrew klavin from the daily wire
before that video is pinned Below in the
description uh that was a few years ago
it was around the time my book was just
released and he or or his people
contacted me to come on to talk about
marriage and divorce stuff that I was
talking about in my book and I thought
we had a very productive conversation
um he was open to hearing things he
pushed back and some things I'm
completely open to talk to any of these
daily wire people they want to have a
conversation or a debate or whatever it
is I'm happy to do that I don't think
they'll do it though because it's a
no-win situation for them there's just
no way that the argument that they're
going to present is is going to defeat
the problems that exist with it Manning
up isn't going to solve it Jordan
Peterson had the worst take on it ever
man just go watch that podcast that I
did breaking down his three-part Series
so family court system must be torn down
and rebuilt really you're going to tear
who exactly is going to tear it down and
rebuild it you and the track con crew
you're going to petition to have that
changed how's that going you know where
are the Bills in Parliament that are
going to be entertained uh the thing
with the family loss system today is
sorry let me just rewind a little bit so
we live in uh a matriarchy today we
don't live in a patriarch we live in a
matriarch it's a female first primary
social order you know you've heard this
before
everything in in family law that has
been passed over the decades listen over
the last few years decades again
everything in there has been passed to
protect women and children men are
disposable we've always been disposable
throughout history nobody really gives a
[__] about men they keep telling you oh
they oh they care about you but they
don't they really just don't care about
men men have always been disposable
they're always going to be disposable
women are protected it's always been
that way that's why when the ship hits a
freaking Iceberg and the Titanic went
down it's Women and Children First and
they all got on the Life Yacht and all
the guys basically crowned right
um that's the way that the system works
by default so you think that you're
going to change the laws that are
written there to protect women I mean
the the notion of um deadbeat dads
exists and and that and that sound bite
has existed for decades again because
there were legitimately some douchebag
guys that would have children and just
walk you know walk away from your
obligations and
uh she was left uniformation destitute
so they created things like child
support and alimony to extract money
from you give it to her the problem with
it though is that they went real real
far with the language and had it so
broadly written that it's an advantage
to women to be deceptive to take
advantage of it for control and for
money again I cover it in the chapter in
my book in Great Lengths and detail get
the unplugged Alpha and read it if you
haven't read it you will it will make
sense to you okay you're not gonna tear
down and rebuild the family court system
anytime in your lifetime probably
definitely in my lifetime either it's
not going to happen
then he says the red pill has no
Solutions today
sure red pill the manosphere whatever
it's he calls it a surrender
now
I use the term surrender from time to
time
like for example you need to surrender
to the fact that water is wet and that
you can't breathe underwater
just not you can't walk into a [__]
ocean and keep breathing like you're
breathing air when you're underwater you
need to just render the fact that water
is wet you will die if you try to
breathe it the Sun is hot if you go out
in the bright sunshine in your pale skin
white dude in the freaking desert in
Arizona you'll get a sunburn you're
going to be very badly damaging and
hurting for days and end up with some
issues you know with your skin obviously
so you have to surrender certain
realities that exist in the world so if
you want to call surrendering to the
notion that marriage is a bad idea fine
Matt Walsh or whoever else that wants to
use that term
um
it's it's an acceptance
of the reality it's what it is
women aren't
what they were decades ago they weren't
what existed in my parents and
grandparents and great grandparents
Generations women have a long laundry
list of Demands of men
uh men don't meet most of that long
laundry list of Demands that women are
expecting women are also bringing to the
table a lot of baggage a lot of uh you
know like notches a very large Notch
count they've shared their body with
multiple men you know they go on talking
about they want to demand monogamy from
a man but if they've shared their body
with 20 or 30 other guys and then claim
that they've gotten right with God or
whatever it is they want to get right
with and they're now ready to settle
down you can't erase your pals choices
you can't erase the fact that you've
shared your body with 20 30. 50 100
other guys you just can't if you have
a predisposition if you have evolved
yourself to the point where you're used
to moving from one guy to the other to
the other when things don't work out
when you don't get your way
um if things are like if your cup isn't
filled by whatever it is that you know
he needs to do for you and you know
you're at guy number 51 who cares if
number 52 comes along because you'll
find 53 and 4 and 5. you know they
always think there's something bigger
and better on the other side you know
when you get to that sort of situation
um so accepting
that this is a reality of the women that
come to the table today and it's not
just data some of the problem there's
lots of other problems entitlement uh
bratty Behavior a lot of them bring
children from prior relationships you
know in my grandparents age in my
parents age uh there was almost no
single mothers you know you go back a
few a few hundred years like even as
recent as a few hundred years if a woman
became a single mother she was at the
bottom of the totem pole as far as being
entertained for livestock or for mother
stock or for any of those things uh they
were generally resigned to brothels and
stuff like that right the very very
bottom and it sounded you know today now
they're celebrated they can bring kids
from two different fathers three
different fathers it doesn't matter
um there's women on dating apps people
send me these screenshots all the time I
got tired of sharing them on social
media and and Twitter because there's so
many of them where women are on dating
apps legitimately pregnant with the seed
of another man in their belly holding
themselves themselves out to be of value
and wife and marriage material I want to
be a stay-at-home mom I've got a
three-year-old and a seven-year-old and
I'm pregnant right now and I want to be
a stay-at-home mom
are you freaking kidding me this is what
men are dealing with today but you know
tribecon say just man up and do it man
you know because you're an individual
you're different have honest
communication state in principle no
divorce from the outset have shared
Faith have shared values abolish no
fault divorce all these sorts of things
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out